an investigation is underway after a
passenger plane started violently
shaking in midair a suspected engine
failure is to blame 359 passengers were
on the AirAsia X flight from Western
Australia to Malaysia the plane safely
returned to earth after the continuous
shaking began Kris Van Cleave is in
Washington with how passengers described
the ride Chris good morning good morning
passengers on board the Airbus a330
report it was like being inside a
washing machine with violent vibrations
shaking the cabin for nearly two hours
this video captured onboard AirAsia X
flight D 70 237 shows the Airbus a330
rattling through the sky shaking the
nerves of the 359 people on board
one passenger posted this video on
Instagram writing I thought I might die
it was just like a small explosion
almost from the left wing um and the
plane just started shuddering passengers
say the pilot twice came over the
intercom telling them to quote pray the
flight was on its way to kuala lumpur
from western australia but was forced to
turn around after what the Australian
Transportation Safety Bureau called a
serious incident an in-flight engine
fault suddenly we heard a like him hang
nose and then everything is start
shaking then the captain said that we
have to go back to earth
adding to the crisis this view from the
window shows the planes engine shaking
uncontrollably the passengers were told
to brace for possible impact on landing
but arrived safely back in Perth thank
God like you know the pilot was really
good and he's done a really really great
job
and I'm really thankful for them that
airliner is being checked over by
engineers and remains grounded
passengers took a flight out later to
Malaysia accompanied by the same pilot
this is the third issue with that type
of engine on the a330 since May Gayle
Wow thank you Chris it does sound like
the pilot that did a good job but you
didn't seem fair
comforting you know part of the thing
look to is the crew to see how they're
doing the passenger said looking at the
flight attendant and listening to the
pilot maybe even more scared about
telling you to pray yes I don't think
anyone needs to tell me at that point
when you're shaking that much Wow hear
that from the pilot thank you Chris